bonjour david alors je le disais le
dispositif de sécurité conséquent et un
convoi même été interpellé porte de
saint cloud c'est bien cela
oui alors on estime à plus de 300 le
nombre de verbalisations distribuer ce
matin par les forces de l'ordre un
dispositif de sécurité impressionnant et
est conséquent pour éviter le blocage de
la capitale près de sept mille deux
cents policiers des gendarmes ont été
déployés dans paris à le préfet 10 et
l'allemand a déployé tous les moyens
humains et militaires afin d'éviter le
blocage de la capitale malgré ça malgré
cette artillerie l'eau cette artillerie
riez lourdes et bien les manifestants
certains manifestants ont réussi à
s'infiltrer ici à sur les champs elysées
l'objectif est de manifester
pacifiquement et discrètement à toute
forme de manifestation peut être
verbalisé immédiatement par exemple le
port d'un drapeau le port d'un simple
tee shot peut donner lieu à des
verbalisations c'est ce qu'on a pu
constater ici un sur les champs elysées
l'arc de triomphe est entouré par des
cars de policiers et gendarmes également
des blindés de gendarmes c'est une
première depuis les manifestations des
gilets jaunes en 2018 et puis ce convoi
de la liberté doivent rire vous
l'écoutez derrière moi est arrivé est en
train d'arriver actuellement sur les
champs elysées oui comme vous pouvez
entendre autour de moi sur ces images de
sébastien dufour et bien ils ont réussi
à s'infiltrer réussira à passer les
barrages de police pour arriver sur les
champs elysées accueillis comme des
héros un paradou toutes les personnes
que vous voyez ici sur ces images avec
des cris et de joie les forces de
l'ordre ne sont pas intervenues pour le
moment le top départ était donné
énormément à 13h15 et les voilà qui sort
est arrivé voilà pour dénoncer les
actions du gouvernement depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire a dénoncé
également
mesures liberticides
1 mise en place par l exécutif a depuis
le début la crise sanitaire et voilà les
champs elysées l'avenue des champs
elysées est en train d'être prises
d'assaut par les manifestants en direct
sur ces images 1 de sébastien dufour
l'objectif a été atteint pour ses 1
personne c'était de prendre d'abord les
champs elysées et vous le voyez c'est
maintenant mise en place directement les
forces de l'ordre étaient dépassés
puisque pour l'instant aucune
intervention à des policiers des
gendarmes ne sont venus interpeller à
ses 1 personne et vous le voyez il
envahit sens totalement l'avenue des
champs elysées c'est assez incroyable ce
qui se passe sous nos yeux sous vos yeux
ici en direct sur rt france puisque il
était question effectivement qu'ils
viennent d'une minute à l'autre sur les
champs elysées sans pour autant avoir de
certitude sur ces informations et puis
d'un coup vous avez vu ils sont arrivés
les forces de l'ordre commencent à
intervenir regarder juste derrière mon
caméraman ça commence à se mettre en
place un pour menacer l et un
manifestant et intervenir afin de
bloquer cette action action du convoi de
la liberté organisée depuis un deux puis
à de nombreux jours c'était une
succession de deux problèmes en deux à
surmonter pour ces personnes qui ont un
se sont vu interdire de manifester la
préfecture de police a été être fr vous
le voyez regardez là bas alors me
demande de partir vous voyez les
drapeaux
[Musique]
et c'est nécessaire à ces un
exceptionnel ce qui se passe puisque je
vous le disais
la préfecture de police a été ferme et
inflexible pour contrer ce mouvement
pour contrer tout le cash de la capitale
et finalement à force de détermination
et d'envié pour ces manifestantes il
dénonça ces mesures liberticides du
gouvernement ils sont parvenus à envahir
les champs-elysées un grand un grand
moment pour le à un moment où la joie
aussi on imagine et voilà vous voyez
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
immédiate un qui commence à gaz et ils
commencent à gazer et intervenir de
manière assez ferme et inflexible à ce
sont les mots du préfet didier lallement
à ne rien laisser passer ne rien laisser
passer
je lève vivent les images vous le voyez
[Musique]
un des images valent mieux que des mots
et vous voyez à quel point la police est
intervenue de manière extrêmement rapide
pour tenter de bloquer cette opération
cette action coup de poing
véritable défi relevé par le convoi de
la liberté 1 souvent est interdit
de toute manifestation aujourd'hui voilà
vous entendez les manifestants scander
la marseillaise et scandé le mot liberté
pour ces personnes venues de toute la
france à je rappelle qu'ils sont sur les
routes depuis plusieurs jours regardez
sont en train d'organiser un sit-in
juste sous vos yeux à s'asseoir sur
l'arc de triomphe va s'asseoir sur cette
place de l'étoile symbole de la de la
capitale symbole
d'une france révolté c'est ce qu'on peut
dire aussi d'une phase fatigué par ces
mesures
sanitaires prises par l'exécutif depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire des
mesures liberticides et des mesures
qu'il considère un club
comme voilà comment un blocage pur pour
vivre normalement tout simplement on
bride leur liberté d'expression
également c'est ce qu'on a pu entendre
un dans leurs mots puisque je vous le
rappelle ils n'étaient pas autorisés à
manifester aujourd'hui la préfecture de
police a été très clair sur le sujet
plus de 300 verbalisations ont eu lieu
et c'est ce qui a moins à mon avis on va
avoir lieu également dans les prochaines
minutes puisque la police ne compte rien
laissé un passé et verbaliser chacune
deux de ces personnes
puisque je le rappelle la préfecture à
annappes a autorisé à toute forme de
manifestation aujourd'hui dans la
capitale
david mercier 1 pour toutes ces
précisions on va garder un saisie mais
voilà une action on dirait merci
beaucoup à david en tout cas on va vous
laisser